[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et si et si nous osions est revenu c'est
une illusion être vrai si nous devions
être nature sans maquillage sans costume
cravate rose et l'authenticité de
l'instant
[Musique]
osez authenticité l'instant parfois
c'est accueillir la dissonance
technologique accepter la soi-disant
possible alors au quotidien cette fois
dix en dix ans les soi-disant pousse
notre technologie qu elle prend la forme
souvent dans le chaos d'une mélasse d'un
volcan ou au contraire d'un désert plus
concrètement au quotidien c'est la
colère la tristesse la vanille et
manière générale en fait c'est avec ça
c'était comme un reçu je dois juste pas
avoir les dents qui claquent en plein
communauté direction surtout pas comment
ça se fait que j'ai hurlé à ce point là
sur mon fils hier soir
et pourtant ce cas au 7 mai à ce volcan
est là et il est là les ans les cellules
ilm incorpore et ils m'embarque
complètement la difficulté en fait que
nous avons simplement à surfer avec nos
émotions
elle tient en un mot la culpabilité je
n'aurais pas dû il ne faut pas je ne
bois pas il ya qu'à faut qu'on
avec la liste qui va avec et de fait la
culpabilité
avec ça je me crise je me réjouis d'y
fille je me solidifie et jusqu'à en
devenir
pétrie et du coup je me coupe de ce pied
présent de cette mélasse de ce volcan de
ce chaos
exc alors quotidien pour accueillir
cette mélasse ce chaos et cetera
peut-être que on peut essayer cette
petite chose qui ait le courage
déjà le courage de ressentis fpt ce qui
ce passe de ressentir ces neuf entre de
ressentir cette gorge qui à ce très
lourd lot de ressentir ma tête qui
devient comme un étau juste de faire ce
corps à corps avec ça en fait de le
devenir pleinement
c'est aussi le courage parfois de mettre
des mots sur ce qui est à l'intérieur
des prix mais ce qui est la bête
juste je suis une formation en plusieurs
sessions dans roues il ya un homme avec
lequel je suis en rejet immédiat
je me connais absolument pas je ne sais
pas qui c'est c'est totalement
irrationnelles comme le saut de toute
façon les émotions
la vie est bien faite on va faire des
exercices je me retrouve en binômes à
plusieurs reprises avec cet homme là et
j'essaye de surfer avec ma menace
intérieure il ya bruit leur sang il
vient boire et écoute ya des choses qui
match contre nous je vois là je sens que
ça fait pas pour toi et je prends le
temps de lui exprimer
caen fait avec lui je vis de la
répulsion et il accuse le choc c'est pas
du tout confortable pour lui ça n'est
pas tellement pour moindre but à zéro
vrai on en reste là pour un temps le
limbourg mais comme je vais le voir et
je n'en voyais avec ça ce matin
hédi ben c'est vrai que ouais la chaux
qui à la tristesse la colère est là et
impétueux je suis dans l'incompréhension
pas je comprends pas pourquoi tu dis ça
et en même temps que je dois bien
admettre que c'est pas la première fois
que quelqu'un me dit qu'il vit de la
répulsion visa minois et moi je les ai
entendus intellectuellement
j'ai senti que mon intérêt capter ces
mots et à un moment donné j'ai senti mon
coeur qui a fait et là j'ai senti qu'un
bon avaient été créés contre lui et moi
on s'est croisé à notre reprise dans la
formation a continué à poser les vous
est en fait de moments où on a tissé un
fils de guérison pour lui comme pour moi
parce que bien
il y avait une souffrance en miroir de
part et d'autre donc ce que peuvent
ouvrir ce courage du ce corps à corps
avec les émotions de ce choeur à coeur
avec nos émotions
c'est simplement la confiance en soi la
confiance en l'autre et ça ça n'a juste
aucun prix imaginer des entreprises
alors la jupe en freestyle imagine les
entreprises ou les autres les émotions
c'est paul baehr je pense que ça ne sera
pas d'entreprise et bisounours
je pense que sympa le champ de bataille
je pense que l'entreprise parce que
justement les émotions sont ouvertes
sera en concentré sur sa raison d'être
sa mission et son rayonnement donc oui
oui à nos émotions parce que tout
simplement c'est la vie qui cherchent à
perdre et à travers mais limitation à
travers mes croyances travers mes
souffrances à travers mes blessures elle
cherche simplement à faire lumière
derrière mais ouvre je suis le
développement de tous mais possible je
suis les i still attention de tous mes
sauts mais je suis l'equilibre
improbable dans l'éternel azur de mai à
léa permanent aux et l'authenticité de
l'unss parfois tendres quotidien c'est
être à l'écouté de cette mélodie
particulière de ces sonorités nouvelles
c'est entendre cette petite voix qui
insiste de manière sûre
il néanmoins lancinante qui inscrit pour
que enfin je prenne ce chemin de
traverse que enfin j'arrête de répéter
ce que j'ai répété répété et répété
pendant des heures enfin juste jeu sorti
de ma zone de confort que j'aille et que
jose aller vers cet inconnu
c'est dans notre quotidien
tout simplement ce que nous connaissons
l'intuition et pour autant ce que nous
mettons comme frein avec ça en tout cas
ce que nous avons comme frein vis-à-vis
nos intuitions c'est que elle guide
quelque part et nous invite à les ans le
vide et la peur du vide
laporte a maîtrisé la peur de ne pas
savoir la peur de perdre mes repères
habituels
mes croyances ah ben ça c'est le clip
total dont j'ai virage s'est jetée
entendu mais en fait je fais comme ça
parce que moi être rassurés j ai
peut-être que dans le quotidien ce qui
peut nous aider à cheminer en fait vers
toujours plus des comptes de cette
intuition et bien ça porte un petit mot
qu'on a déjà revendu aujourd'hui
l'audace l'audace contient du génie du
pouvoir et de la magie que tu juste
cette intuition ce que ça leur ouvre ij
dans votre quotidien à chacun d'entre
nous pour nous tous
et bien c'est pas c'est ni plus ni moins
pour la confiance
pour la vie c'est l'ouverture à cet
espace pratique dont on parle déjà
depuis plus d'un siècle
c'est l'ouverture à cette intelligence
de la vie dont nous faisons partie qui
ne dépassait king5 plus en même temps
c'est l'ouverture aux synchronicité ces
ouvertures à une certaine fluidité nous
pas que le chemin où l'expérience soit
il y facile
une gare les ados elle s'attarde pas du
tout mais simplement que le chemin ainsi
parcourus nous enrichit nous embellie et
nous inspire nouvellement est
profondément
alors oui oui un cuissot qui nous guide
pas à pas oui à ses intuitions
simplement qu'ils tirent toujours vers
un nouveau et imagine la vie je suis la
fragrance qui me porte ici plutôt que là
je suis gps qui s'est ici plutôt que là
n'a pas l'importance que je lui accorde
je suis le nid à coucher à la falaise
qui se réduit d' être authentique
j'ai entendu ya pas très longtemps par
une amie que étymologiquement cela
voulait dire être sa propre autorité
alors quand j'ai entendu ça j'ai fait
autorité et autoritarisme il car j'ai
tout mon côté militaire justement avait
une hausse certes pas et a fait j'ai
cheminé et c'est ce que j'aime bien
cheminer avec ce qui me dérange et j
sortie ou fur et à mesure que je malaxe
et ses propositions que c'était une
invitation à le redresser
d'une part et à me détendre
d'autre part je ne suis pas 100 %
d'authenticité ou peut-être si le
suis-je seconde après seconde
invariablement une chose est sûre c'est
que ce que cela change dans ma vie c'est
être responsable
acteur et auteur de ma vie responsable
de mes émotions est responsable de mes
décisions
j'écris ma vie être ma propre autorité
c'est aussi être libre enfin j arrête
d'écouter ces voix qui me jugent qu'ils
juste que j'ai fait qu'ils jugent les
envies qui juge les comparaisons qui
juge dit et j'arrête aussi d'écouter le
jugement de pierpoljak je reste à
l'écouté mais je suis plus dépendante de
sa être ma propre dorit et c'est aussi
osé faire un palan lui s'est lâché le
résultat au profit de l'expérience du
moment
le résultat parfois satisfait
l'expérience elle enrichit
systématiquement être ma propre autorité
je constate aussi que c'est être surpris
surpris de ce que je peux devenir ce
prise de qui je suis que je n'imaginais
pas être devenir ce prix zara d'être à
un endroit où je n'imaginais pas être
être se prive également par la vie et
accepter d'être embellie par elle à
travers toutes ces propositions est
aussi intuition et enfin être ma propre
autorité
[Musique]
je constate que c'est être à la fois
humble il fier c'est accueillir mon
arrogance et mon orgueil et croyez moi
j'en ai un paquet au profit de l'être
humain que je suis ici alors oui oui à
tout tout ce que nous sommes tous deux
qui vit en moi tout seul
lui autour de moi oui c'est harry
inconditionnel je suis prête
je suis libre je dis ni je vois la porte
l'air ne respirent l'infini ap
je dis oui je suis le wifi ces quelques
phrases que j'ai pu vous lis ou vous
dire je les ai écrites ya une semaine
dimanche dernier lors d'un stage
d'écriture spontanée pour simplement
nourrir ma propre tente ici tu es encore
et encore
il est d'initier les déposer aujourd'hui
25 mars 2010 est devant vous c'est ma
façon de m'engager encore toujours plus
puissants vis à vis de vous deux mois de
la vie avec un petit peu comme un
mariage centaines de témoins ce qui
n'est pas tous les jours
alors et vous demain 1 quelle
dissonances intérieur allez vous dire
oui
qu'allez vous accueillir comme feeling
nouveau et particuliers dans votre
quotidien
osons ozon être cette vie qui nous en
mairie sans cesse et sans cesse va
chercher juste simplement le meilleur de
ce que nous sommes et ensemble c'est
tellement possible merci
[Applaudissements]